what are the goals and ambitions that
you're bringing to this tournament
yo obviously i'm just looking to play
some good games i think
unlike prior years i'm not really
looking for a particular result i'm just
really trying to enjoy chess um
for me this is you know one of the one
of the few tournaments i have planned
for the year so you know it's not
something that i'm putting myself um
under too much pressure for i mean
obviously i'd like to like win some
games and play really well
but um more than just like a result i
really wanted to play good chefs and um
and just be satisfied with my uh my play
this tournament okay i mean i hope to
play a good chess obviously just get a
it's a pretty tight tournament anyone
can win i'll want to fight fight fight
for the top spots at least and okay
another personal goal is to get to 2500
i'm pretty close so well i'd be i'm
playing against like some of the best
juniors across the us i just want to
play my best and prove that like
i can do well and i just hope that i can
use this opportunity to the best of my
ability
most mainly just take it game by game
and not not i'm not thinking too much
about the end result but
more just move by move and
staying in good shape this is a very
strong tournament i i think i'm second
seed in this tournament i hope to win
this tournament i'll do whatever i can
to do it well i i mean i'm not having
i'm not really having any like specific
goal for the tournament i mean not not
really anything specific in terms of
results
um
not nothing crazy i'm just trying to
take it one game at a time um focus on
what i can control and that's about it
just doing my best and being happy with
what i can do i'm gonna be honest i
don't really have much of a goal except
not to
lose too badly
i think that's like a fair standard to
hold myself to
be a good tournament and this will be
really embarrassing if i end up playing
really badly
but i'm just gonna say it now
[Music]